[Music]
these are the faces of women who have
come to represent progress
rwanda has has led the world and the
levels of women
in its parliament now for over a decade
nearly two-thirds of rwanda's parliament
is made up of women
that's more than twice the global
average
countries that have more women in power
tend to have
better outcomes for development so
better outcomes for child mortality
um better outcomes for um education
countries that have higher levels of
women in
their government and also just general
better levels of gender equality
more broadly are more likely to be
stable and secure
but the origins of rwanda's high female
representation
stem from the country's darkest moment
women must know that things have changed
we can
do we can equally do what men can do the
whole world now wants to run from random
about gender about women in rwanda
how are they developing how what are
they achieving
while rwanda leads the world in female
representation
the motivations of the ruling party have
raised questions about the true extent
of women's power
in april 1994 rwandan president juvenal
happy romana was killed when his plane
was shot down near the country's capital
kigali
the assassination ignited ethnic
tensions between the majority hutu
and the minority tutsi tribes in 100
days of hatred
800.000 died the violence would leave a
tenth of the population dead
while the conflict was undoubtedly
framed by ethnicity
its effect on women was undeniable
the genocide was planned not just
killing
but other things rape was a reward the
leaders gave to those who cared
most women had been gang-raped
that was very traumatic so many of them
were mutilated
the women were targeted because of who
they were
and it shocked the world to see that
even
your own husband whom you have given
beautiful children
turns around and distraught as you
because you become you belong
to that ethnic group
many others were you know disconnected
and kind of separated from their
children
from their families in spite of this
horror
it was women who would rebuild the
country it is now among the most stable
countries in africa
average incomes have tripled education
healthcare tourism and trade
are all improving dramatically rwandan
leader paul kagame
has been assailed by international
observers for suppressing political
opponents and descent
sometimes violently but he and his
ruling party the rpf
have also been praised for stabilizing
the country and setting it on a course
of recovery
part of this redevelopment was enabling
rwandan women
who had found themselves taking on new
roles that had traditionally belonged to
men
burying the dead building homes as well
as housing half a million orphans
i'm always thinking of stories of that
that women have told me over the years
about how before
the genocide they were a housewife and
they were living sort of
um you know kind of day-to-day raising
children
um cooking caring further further for
their
plot of land and how in the aftermath of
the violence they found themselves alone
and completely realizing that they
needed to act they needed to
pull people together they needed to um
to do
something to be able to survive the
utterly
abysmal and horrible conditions of life
especially in rural communities in the
aftermath of
the bloodshed land has gone fallow
massive displacement
i mean about 50 of the population was
displaced from their homes and so you
see a total erosion of social networks
um you know you no longer have your
community to be with you have to forge
new networks and forge new um um
you know ways of of of providing for
your for your
for yourself and for your children and
for others in your community
just a few years after the violence
women had formed an estimated 15
400 organizations across the country
initially with a focus on grief trauma
and support
mary balacan gary founded the rwanda
women's network
in where our safe space you could meet
and cry
talk about our challenges
talk about issues that really concern us
but the same time ask ourselves what
should we do
so out of that safe space women have
learned to plan
to organize to take awareness to their
fair women
and eventually to connect the whole
thinking
to the whole political thinking of the
country
and in that journey of safety has
given us the power to know that you can
change a society
some of these organizations would evolve
into vocational training and
profit-making businesses
by joining together and formalizing
their structure groups could become
eligible for economic benefits from ngos
or the government in the process of
formalizing they established a president
a vice president a secretary of
treasurer
and this provided really a kind of a
platform for women's leadership within
these
really nascent small community
organizations
that then women could use to to kind of
um support their increased engagement
in politics this increasing engagement
of women in what had been a typical
patriarchy would have a broader social
impact
from the clothes they wore to the
businesses they started to run
ideas of what women should be were about
to change
when you look back before the colonial
era
definitely women where you know where
we are very active active but yet
invisible
and that's the typical patriarchal
uh society that most african countries
are patriarch is a very hard system
to undo it it takes
it takes time because it is culturally
grounded
to begin undoing this system there was
one aspect of rwandan society that
needed to change quickly
land rights with more than 90 of
rwandans dependent on agriculture for
their livelihood
access was vital in the recovery women's
organizations mobilized to take control
of land owned by deceased family members
in 1999 the succession law was passed
granting women the right to inherit land
and property for the first time
this would set the stage for subsequent
legislation that established children's
rights
and protection against gender-based
violence at the time
the inheritance laws were not there and
so we had to fight for it in order to
make sure
that women are able to inherit their
husbands properties
we want to be able to forcefully
put forward the women's needs because
women's needs
are not men's needs and nobody will talk
about women's needs
better than you as a woman
with just 20 judges left alive after the
genocide
more women also became involved in
gachacha courts
village-based justice proceedings
designed to try
hundreds of thousands accused of crimes
during the genocide
by 2001 about 35 percent of newly
elected gacha judges
were women
then in august 2003 a new constitution
was written
as well as committing to fight the
ideology of genocide and eradicate
ethnic divisions
the constitution also pursues gender
equality
it states that women are granted at
least 30
of posts in decision-making organs
research shows that 30 is the critical
mass of women in power needed to make a
substantial difference in politics
in rwanda those seats are elected by
voters from local women's councils
but women are also able to contest seats
outside of this allocation
in the first election after the genocide
women won
48 of seats this really was
um uh i think evidence uh
of a broader swell of support um
both kind of from the political
leadership as well as from the
grassroots
uh for women's women's and political
participation in this sort of new
rebuilding rwanda those sort of informal
grassroots self-help projects became
the foundation for building a more
engaged kind of political
um kind of population of women
the narrative was changed before it was
only a matter of dominated
space but now we are together in it
so the more we continue to engage
ourselves with them
and the more we continue to raise on
them
and that's why we said the narrative is
changing
and it has changed for good by the next
election in 2013
the number of women elected rose to 64
led by paul kagame the ruling party the
rwandan patriotic front
has made women's inclusion a hallmark of
its programme for post-genocide recovery
and reconstruction
but despite the significant steps in
female empowerment
and broader development following the
genocide human rights advocates are
highly critical of the way in which
kogami's party runs the country
freedom house ranks rwanda as not free
with concern about rights and liberties
human rights watch says the government
displays a marked intolerance of the
most basic forms of dissent
amnesty's national rates report in the
lead up to the 2017 election
that talks about opposition politicians
journalists human rights defenders being
jailed physically attacked even killed
absolute rubbish is completely different
from what it was
25 years ago and although the rpf
welcomed women into politics
critics suggest the motives aren't as
noble as once thought
women who were seen as less complicit in
the genocide
could be used to the party's advantage
many of the oldest and most kind of
fierce leaders within
civil society were brought into
government
so that they could be i think greater
kind of
policed um in a way that um is
is really has been detrimental for the
kind of
growth of democracy in rwanda
i think the notable thing about the
women's seats is that they are not
affiliated with a political party
so they are just women's seats and so
critics have
have really suggested that this has
allowed the rwandan patriotic front
to cement an even greater political
control over the parliament
because while the number of seats held
by rpf members is
is whatever it is the number of seats
that are held by rpf
kind of um supporters and and and
and you know those closely affiliated
with the party
um are are often on the women's tickets
and so they're not actually
they're not actually recorded as being a
member of a political party while
they're in office
when we look at the cases of diane
reguara or victoire in gabire
these are two women that have dared to
challenge president kagame
for the presidency and both were met
with
extreme sanctions they were thrown in
jail
i think those cases are really
illustrative in
showing the limits of the story of
women's empowerment in rwanda
we we do see these kind of amazing
levels of women in government
but at the same time what you know what
power does
a does a parliament have if they are
completely under the control of the
executive
women have power um to the extent
that what they're interested in and
working on does not
conflict with the goals of the regime so
there have been some kind of notable i
think
pieces of legislation especially around
gender-based violence
that women parliamentarians in rwanda
have pushed forward
and which have made important impressive
sort of legislative
change in the country
despite this legislation levels of
violence against women remain high
estimates in 2010 found 41 of women have
experienced some form of physical
violence since the age of 15
rising to 56 for married women
we see it really the the
the challenge in in assuming that
women's political
um empowerment translates or trickles
down
to women's empowerment writ large right
we see
remarkably high rates of gender-based
violence of intimate partner violence
we see remarkably high rates of women's
economic disenfranchisement
the story on rwanda tends to be quite
polarized just 25 years after
uh absolutely catastrophic um and
and and and horrific violence you see
a country that hasn't seen a return to
bloodshed you see a country where
there have been profound increases in
longevity
in health in education you know and
and that that story is one of that
really should
be celebrated and commended and then on
the other hand
this authoritarian state that has
completely uh jeopardized its
population's well-being
by shutting down dissent by um by
conducting widespread extrajudicial
killings
these two stories are mutually
compatible
they are both true and i think the you
know the reality is that the rwanda's
developmental progress has been made
possible by its authoritarian
nature right rwanda's success in terms
of
not having another outbreak of violence
has been
possible because of its massively robust
military and security apparatus
some of the gains women have made are
undermined by the authoritarian nature
of the state
disproportionate numbers of wealthy
foreign-born tutsi women sit at the top
of the table
which means new forms of inequality are
developing in rwanda
impacting the incredible progress women
made in the immediate aftermath of the
violence
rwanda leads the world when it comes to
the number of women in power
but it's only one part of the bigger
picture of equality
for me the the real the real lesson of
rwanda is that
getting women into politics is only one
of many
things we must do to actually
you know increase women's power and more
importantly dismantle forms of
oppression against women
if the level of women in government is
not matched by a corresponding kind of
strong women's movement
rooted in civil society then the women
in government
are almost always going to be tokenized
that sort of corresponding
need for women in government and kind of
the the restructuring
of the economy of kind of the kind of
patriarchal
roots of the family and of society um
and
and of of changing kind of um the the
the systems of governance as well
like that's the way that we build a more
gender equal
future this process we are going through
as a country i call it every birth
i must say that rwanda when you compare
it to other african countries
we are definitely fortunate because we
have a system
a system that responds to the needs of
women so we keep reminding ourselves
that we worked for it and we deserve it
we are now
saying we need to raise our sons and
daughters differently
we've come to understand because we have
enjoyed the new opportunities that the
new rwanda offers
and doing what is undoable
is tough let's continue but the same
time
make sure that the generation to come
sees things differently
[Music]
you